too welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
i'm here with oliver tree against my
will i'm here in protest only fulfilling
an obligation
uh he's a musical artist
he's the
he's the guy on tick tock who goes
why go live goes only 99 all right stop
he's the on and on guy from tick tock
i don't like him his music sucks this is
all over tree you literally invited me
on here to apologize are you gonna
apologize
yes
that was the you texted me begging me to
come on like you made an obligation i
said [ __ ] off ethan you look like an
idiot right now what are you even
wearing look at your stupid little hat
i came
to bury the hatchet
but i said i'm not gonna let this cowboy
kid show me i'm here to make a mockery
of my life's work
all you do is you just make fun of me
and bully me and countless others and
yet you came knowing that
you lied to me and you said you would be
on my side making an apology publicly so
everyone could see and this is not what
we talked okay let me make an apology
make an apology i apologize to my fans
let me interrupt you uh can you uh call
out the sponsors it's more important
than apologizing to oliver oh i have to
thank the sponsors what are you talking
about just wait i have to thank the
sponsors just be just don't talk for
like 15 seconds i can't do that spot
thank you to our sponsors babble
honey me undies and expressvpn and then
i'm gonna need you to say
thank and then repeat after me thank you
to babel
no i'm not doing that thank you to honey
no
so here i'm gonna make an apology i'm
sorry i apologize to my fans
to have to endure this two-hour
nightmare why are you making this worse
why are you doing this
what do you want to do why are you here
you're the only person that shows up
with a laptop to my show i have two
laptops how many do you have why do you
have two laptops brother i come prepared
yeah we had twitter beef i said you know
because first of all you were supposed
to come on last week and you canceled
right why'd you cancel you never even
told me i'm not gonna ever say
you didn't let's just put it this way
you did not make it accommodating to me
or my team okay you did not pay us the
max amount we asked for
you weren't willing to do it and you
gave this other guy all this money
you're gonna fly them out first class
tickets yeah why do you think everyone
wants to go because nicocado actually a
celebrity you're like
you're the only guy
you're the on and on and on guys look at
you dude you've fallen off
life goes
out right there that's the most viral
moment of your entire life how does it
feel
this is not the most viral this is it
here you go i said oliver hey oliver
tree stop wasting my time
either do the show or don't i can't keep
planning and canceling my show because
your dumb ass can't commit fair you said
you should be ashamed you want to read
yours yeah i'd love to i'd love to go
ahead you should be ashamed of the way
you act online you're a grown-ass man
with a child set a better example this
is not any way to conduct a business
although i wouldn't exactly call what
you do a job you're a glorified tabloid
aka scum of the earth bottom feeder and
yes i do mean that so what if mine isn't
a job what is yours bro cause like
literally what is your job exactly
i am an artista yeah
yeah i make art i create things what do
you do you just try to destroy things
you just try to make your little shitty
little commentary and say oh yeah i know
this i know that what have you done with
your life dude
why you gotta be so mean to me dude like
you know i'm someone has to say this
dude
who the hell else is gonna say it to you
because your team's getting paid too
much to say diddly yeah and your team's
not getting paid at all dude why is it
okay this guy straight up don't let him
get away with that
oliver lives in a house
he's like a cult he makes him dress up
like him
okay and they all live in the same house
together do you pay your guys yes or no
is i'm not going to answer that
who pays for their money i'm not going
to answer that who pays for the rent i'm
not do they make a salary not playing
this are you compliant with california
employment laws
stop ask there you agree you're not
talking about this
ryan come here
come here ryan
stop don't do this to me ryan get on
camera right now
ryan just stay off camera come here he's
his little
ryan it's okay he's he's very shy really
nervous it's okay about this it's okay
right like kind of creeping out please
stop right you're not on screen here
liberty to say anything you can use my
mic
don't say sure ryan come here brian this
is one of his hands ryan not brian i
said ryan
ryan is one of his henchmen come here
ryan does he pay you are you working of
your own freedom ryan don't say anything
this is one of his henchmen of how many
people live in the house with you go
ahead you can talk to them we have 20
people
there's over 60 of us
there's over 60. 16. and
you know he said 60. and does he pay you
does he feed you
no
he said no ryan just get the [ __ ] out of
here dude
and brian are you working against your
will do you need help stop stop link
twice if you need help on camera so they
can see right they can't see your eyes
go please please they can't see your
eyes i'm not supposed to say anything he
says he's not supposed to say anything
ryan go how do you explain that
how do i explain what dude do you touch
them
all right
i'm about to walk
you want to criticize what i do let's
talk about what you do nexium
i don't know what scientology i don't
want to get into it right now bro you
came on for a cordial apology and i'm
not experiencing anything close to that
all right so anyway we argue are you so
sorry or what yeah are you i said sorry
for your bully wasting everybody's time
yeah this is i'm sorry you're not in
jail
for literally running a r kelly style
slave
obsessed with r kelly it makes me wonder
what's going on in that nine million
dollar mansion do you have your
passports
do you have your oliver tree wig
ryan i need to get some passwords for
this board
i'm locked out do you have it your
passports did you get your shots here
let me show you how real singing works
you can go go ahead and help him ryan
don't you touch him
don't you hit him
america
the beautiful
do you have your passports do you have
your oliver tree wig girl did you get
that ski jacket don't leave the house
without my
permission i'm all over the tree
i'm about to walk
let's do the interview let's do the
interview dude
yo can i talk about something though
funny so this is how you no you can't oh
where's my hat why don't you tell me my
hat fell off because dude this is
literally the stupidest show in the
world
and yet you're here yeah and yet i'm
here on the shittiest podcast in all of
the [ __ ] world desperate much no not
desperate then why are you here i came
here because i'm putting on my own
podcast
oliver three it's the number one podcast
in the [ __ ] world bro
ian why'd you put that graphic up
this is the number one podcast ever
that's not a real podcast this is a real
podcast i'd like to bring out my first
guest ladies and gentlemen little ricky
um wait what's got guests
of course i have guests
ricky come out here [ __ ]
ladies and gentlemen
the multiverse has brought the number
one superstar of all time little ricky
why'd you bring a guy on stilts out
come in here ricky
drink that coffee ricky i dare you to
take a sip fake ass alien
wait before you say anything i want to
say little ricky
is the first artist i've signed don't
touch the [ __ ] hat
and little ricky and me have been
working on a mixtape okay for the last
year can we can we shut this down
whatever this is
ricky can we shut down whatever this is
let me just say this he and ricky are
about to change the [ __ ] world yeah
you want to say anything ricky i'm kind
of curious what's going on with little
ricky
okay
that was weird
all right ricky you're learning english
she's still learning english all right
whatever this little gag is what we got
to get back on the rails stop stop don't
touch ricky get it stop just chill hey
stop
you don't even have control of your own
guests bro
all right chill
stop go no
all right this is odd hey hey hey not on
my side
ian turn off the set get hey get out of
here get off my side dude
go ricky i'm gonna push your ass over
out
bro are you don't [ __ ] with me dude all
right all right ricky yeah ab get him
out of here
get him out of here
you're a punk
i took off my wig [ __ ]
jesus
okay dude i didn't come on here to fight
i came on here why are you reconciled
what was left
okay
your worst friend why are there two wigs
here i didn't know there were two wigs
you know what
let's just wrap this up
what do you mean wrap this up i haven't
done my ads yet
this is not working okay
i've got a show plan do you want to do
what i've got or what
first of all what there's a line you
don't come on my side
i don't see the line where's the line
the set okay
if you're going to do your little show
yeah i am going to do my first of all
and turn that off okay
ian turn that off do not turn that off
remember
what are you in whatever you do keep the
show going this is the best podcast in
the world you should be lucky to have
oliver three on your show okay first of
all ian turn turn his set off that's an
order
thank you second of all
you don't you don't cross that line you
cross that line again the show's over
you understand where's my crew at my
crew is supposed to be here too
can we fly my guys in
where's my guys
i need my crew here
i can't run all over three without my
guys well there's no oliver three so
that's not a problem this is oliver
three
number one station in the world okay
let's move on i have actually a show
planned we gotta get back on the rails
here um what is this like what are you
doing in my crew what the [ __ ]
who's that this is my crew that's dan
over there
who is that so who are you
abe who is that who
hi can i help you
i'm dan
here he's dan yeah that's my dan
who's who
who who are you that's jacob that's my
audio engineer he's going to be handling
all the sound taking over oh
don't let him touch you guys who the
[ __ ] is this ruby the cherry look that's
casey that's my right hand man keyboard
player guitar player yeah he's gonna be
he's yeah he's gonna be doing all the
sound here okay is the door locked can
you guys call security like where are
all these people coming hey casey can we
get some of my socks this is the close
second how about this is
why is my double's name dan
okay guys this is a close
hey
casey can i get some sound effects
all right guys this is a closed set nope
what the [ __ ] everybody up
everybody no everybody stay where you're
at
nobody move
boosted
nobody move i'm on the oliver 3 podcast
[ __ ] grandpa ricky sit down
you don't want any trouble it's okay no
hard feelings casey stop it casey get
the [ __ ] out of here
this isn't your show okay leave [ __ ] off
dude
ricky [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of myself
ricky don't leave me hanging ricky
stay there ricky don't [ __ ] move
get off him
do you have a [ __ ] talk about
immigration where's your papers little
ricky ricky don't answer anything you
immigrate here from don't answer are you
even on a visa right now
bro just stop with the questions
okay i'll be doing the questions this is
all over three no that's over they're
out we called swami he's our security he
has a gun he's strapped where where's
straight glock in it bro he's got a
glock swami in here
where is he
he's coming and he has a gun [ __ ] with
me
what the [ __ ]
and lock the doors what okay don't lock
the doors i got more people coming
ian turn that [ __ ] off stop it no
this is oliver three and we're here to
stay dude
stop what the [ __ ] dude
all right all right it's back it's back
damn right it's back
all right you want to talk about like i
just want to get this over with at this
point okay let's get it over with
because i want to get it over with just
as bad
all right where everyone's gone do you
even have any questions you're just
gonna insult me the rest of the time i
did have questions but my enthusiasm for
doing this interview is a little waning
to be honest when you're bringing in
your own crew what do you think i'm
gonna do we're running a podcast the
world's best
your podcast fell the [ __ ] off old man
dude it's never like 12 in the world
old man
why is that stop stop stop stop stop
why the [ __ ] would you do that you want
to talk about [ __ ]
yeah let's get it over with
wrap it up
all right
jesus so we have um
did i mention that you're big you're big
on tick tock apparently
yeah
yeah what it do when's he coming what
are you doing
well yeah you're up to 12 million
followers that's got to be your most
followed social media account right
maybe so how does it feel that
the place people like you the most is
where they get you the less get you the
least i don't even know what that means
like they they can only watch you in
short bits and that's where they like
you the most how does that make you feel
because you make a lot of long-form
content people don't really watch that
well here's the thing
this is how i use
my platforms to promote the long-form
stuff so all of them are short except
for youtube and my youtube is actually
has more followers than your youtube so
i don't really know what you're
yammering on about
i'm just saying people i mean how many
youtube followers do you have because i
know it's less than me how many do you
have i don't know more than you
you don't even know how much you have no
i don't i don't look at that like you
and try to count if you're the one that
brought it up but i know for a fact my
inside team members have told me here's
we've surpassed the h3 podcast so i
don't know what you're complaining about
mommy has a gun okay
hey fake a b
swami has a [ __ ] gun stay there dan
don't move get his gun on screen
swami man don't do not move
swami is has a gun get the [ __ ] out of
him swami pull your gun on him dan don't
go anywhere
swami pull your gun on him
you want to say something why are you
letting these guys in swamps you back
down thank you swami i paid him off what
do you think happened don't let those
guys sit
you stand guard
and you pull out the gun you shoot them
if you need to okay they shoot the kill
you understand
you told us last time you know how to
use that thing okay so time to prove it
swami i just want to say thank you for
letting my guys in thank you so much
man is a legend
thank you yeah what don't thank him all
right just stand post outside okay swami
is your gun loaded is the safety off
oh it's locked yeah okay let's let's
unlock that let's turn the safety off
and just be ready
hey swami is
boosted
that's my man right there
all right thank you swami just stand
guard shoot anyone shoot the kill okay
shoot on site thank you thank you thank
you sami thanks bro you look good today
i like the orange
no no no no no no no no what the [ __ ]
you guys stop stop ethan they're [ __ ]
coming back swami shoot these [ __ ]
do you have pepper spray or something
that's my crew
well ab doesn't do anything so it's fine
all right fake ab what do you want to
say you're on the show now good hey
should we plug some stuff get some
[ __ ] ads going out here what do you
want to say dude we have uh the tour
yeah we got a tour coming we have some
are you even gonna promote the tour
i can't talk about anything okay swami's
pulling out a sword so
you guys might want to leave the premise
at this point dan you might want to
watch out swami brought out the bastard
sword the two-handed bastard that's a
sphy-hander that looks really sharp yeah
ab don't get him with this stabbing
that's my right hand mommy take his arm
off oliver how far do you want me to go
here
it depends do you want to lose an arm
for someone that doesn't even pay you
i would do it i guess damn no how about
your head we have insurance right
how about your head get the [ __ ] off set
i'm sick of this
i just want to do the interview
where are the stop everybody out thank
you swami get the gun out be in a ready
position with your weapon out safety off
shoot the kill okay
i'm sorry guys
thank you bro
this is not how i wanted this thing to
roll out dude all right can we just do
this interview this is not funny no it's
not funny i literally just want you
think i once want me to kill one of your
guys
zombie would never do that dude dude
swami's killed to death ratio is insane
i doubt it
i mean i guess we should about tick tock
we should yeah [ __ ] it all right so
here's your tick tock everybody loves it
what's this [ __ ] that's me playing on
jimmy kimmel a real show
that i did last week goodbye that's
crazy that you went from here
yeah i'm wondering why i went from jimmy
kimmel to the [ __ ] h2 podcast me too
how many people watch jimmy kimmel these
days like like a couple of minutes
a couple mil
more than whatever watches this rinky
ding podcast i know you guys aren't
getting the same plays you used to
actually i have quite what's the
preparation of a like of going of
preparing to do a late night show it's
easy peasy bro i'm a pro i've been doing
this is my fourth one
do you rehearse it like there or how
does it work i just bring out my little
hats and the rest is history do you want
to answer any questions you can do yeah
what's your question i'm asking you a
question how do you prepare for this
what's totally or physically no like
what is the show demand of you the jimbo
kimbles of the world this is an
embarrassing question did you rehearse
go and you go and you play
you just show up yes well there's like a
whole set obviously you guys did some no
that's what the set is always no it's
not i've seen that show before
oh so you do watch jimmy kimmel
sometimes i skipped the musical
you notice on jimmy kimmel on late night
shows they put the musical act at the
very end
would you guys stop [ __ ] laughing
over there so you you guys encourage
this kind of behavior for him to be a
monster dude one of your guys just
stabbed me dude i don't give a [ __ ] oh
my god wait what happened wait who was
that dude the [ __ ] fake a b slash dan
just stabbed me when i tried to get my
chair i'm glad you had it coming
it looked no it looks worse than what it
is it wasn't little ricky the sword got
you yeah the sword got me oh man good
i'm glad
some blood was shed you need first aid
no no i'm good it's just a little nick
yeah oh stop crying about it oliver
that's my boy we don't [ __ ] with a.b hey
bro you guys kicked out my team and i'm
ready to kick you guys out
one by one baby's the first to go he has
to go to the hospital all right
you did jimmy kimmel you were at the
very end obviously
usually when they have big guests they
come and sit on the couch did you sit on
the couch i'm just a musical guest right
we had peter dinklage and then we had me
yeah because usually when there's a big
musical guest they'll sit on the couch
and chat with him a little bit yeah i
played my hit that just went
platinum number 23 on the pop cars 24
alternative radio pop charts it's
alternative radio and pop top 25
ace hot ac top wait so what did you hit
on the pop
25 and what did you hit on the alt 23
you hit 25 on the pop yes how many are
in that list
billions dollars no how many are on the
list what do you mean
what oh it's like they is there like a
top list yeah so when you're on
yeah how many are on the list
i don't know
usually about a hundred oh hundred oh
that's pretty good but we're talking
about all of pop music good
congratulations must be a slow time and
pop yeah it is
not a lot of relationships
all right so you're desperate for
anything man
actually what i want to show is um
yeah actually the life goes on and on is
huge on tick tock i see it in a lot of
videos how did that happen for you did
that happen like kind of by surprise or
what yeah i was all 100 organic and then
i just posted a bunch of old videos that
i had made from the last five years and
uh put the song in the background and
the rest was history it's kind of it
must be nice to
i mean are people really [ __ ]
messing with you on tick tock it's
supposed to be nice to put all your
content up there and have people
actually watch it it's crazy because i
looked and like i used to see your
tick-tock and i was kind of gauging how
i was doing based upon what you were
doing and there was times where i even
got a little jealous i was like wow
ethan like really had a good one today
and then i just look at it recently i i
just feel bad for you the views here are
insane 36 million oh yeah this is an old
bid oh those are all old bro i only
filmed like two videos for it i filmed
114 million what is it oh we got bigger
ones than that
that one's like from a couple months
like a month ago
it's pretty good
especially because that song was popping
so if you click this song you can see
5.5 million videos with this there's
another one with over 4 million then we
have another one with a million but
that's just the people who tagged the
song so
the label told me they're estimating
over 20 million videos with the song
they got to be happy about that they're
not they're pissed well here's the thing
do you get paid from tick tock don't get
paid anything do the label get paid of
course they make a little something no i
don't think they make money off tick
tock
they make money off everything else
which i don't see a dime of
so it's been probable we'll be so i i
last time we talked you you told me that
they fund all your like really expensive
music videos and stuff which we'll get
into we'll watch but are you in debt to
the label is that how it's yeah and so
everything you make millions upon
millions and i'm not going to throw the
number out there but it's way way way
too much
i'll never make that money back it's
essentially a scam but like they got to
give you some money to live right um
peanuts essentially but they give you a
little something maybe something like
that here i've got uh
i've got something here
what is this
so
if we pull up
um life goes on
peak position
36. that's just uh that's not the pop
though
adult pop airplay yeah that's not pop
that's it has been on the charts eight
weeks so that's pretty fire that's not
the pop charts though dawg says adult
pop yeah that's adult pop hot ac
which one should we check check the pop
chart check the pop charts dan
i'm just fact checking you in real time
it does actually say pop like right on
it no it says adult pop airplay yeah
that's the hot ac dog this is the hot ac
dan that's not the pop chart okay you
want the is it is it hi do you want the
ac
okay
you said you said
that's what the chart's called are you
want to turn the ac down yeah turn off
the ac you oh so you're
you're cold
barry
so it's the pop ac it's the hot the hot
ac
okay turn the ac down maybe
oliver's hot
did you find a new one dan i did yeah
this one says number 26. okay no we
broke the 25
well
it says number 26. so you only lied by
one no that's not accurate actually
that's where it is maybe this week but
last week it was 25. it says peak
position peak that's not that's the
highest it's been maybe that's not
updated
i mean the billboard website i know
that's the billboard website all right
well we've established a liar so let's
continue and also alternative charts too
yeah you know what alternate means who
cares
whatever bro anyway that's pretty
amazing 5.5 million views but i've
always wondered the economy
of tick tock with big songs like this
because you're you're you were like
number one on the tick tock fire page
and all that
so you at the label there's not a lot of
money coming out of tick tock for you
guys zero zilch but on the plus side it
does help right the exposure is pretty
incredible
i mean think about it
this thing blew up on tick tock and
where am i back to the same shitty
podcast for the third year in a row so
that's fair enough nothing's really
changed although i did notice the music
video
i will give a shout out to you
my friend
you finally got a hit 130 173 million
views eh
something like that yeah i mean those
numbers slightly off in real time it's
closer to 175 million
well what's the biggest youtube video
you ever did
nothing close to that well there you go
but i make my own money you have to like
pay it to some suit exactly and that's
the thing that's really sad is i'm doing
some of the greatest art of our
generation and i'm left penniless and
then a guy like you a chump like
yourself is living in a 9 million
mansion ain't it a shame yeah it is a
shame and what you sell adult diapers
and that's your main thing adult diapers
yeah what's your ads that you run i
don't sell adult diapers i think you do
i've seen some pictures
i found some on the internet and oh wow
yeah like you found a picture of me
doing a joke and a diaper oh haha what a
funny joke
i thought it was funny at the time bro
just [ __ ] drop it
just plug the tour i'm leaving right now
all right
olivertreemusic.com tour
uh get your tickets it's my last tour
ever
it's the final one
really yes
i'm so sick of touring but these shows
are gonna be epic bro i have so much
crazy stuff planned and little ricky is
coming on the road by the way i want to
come february uh 19. can we come
um
maybe your crew can come i'll bring
swami
swami gets tickets for life but you i
would not want to see you in my green
room i want to be backstage bro can you
bring me on stage
people get psyched if they saw me
they'd be like
uh hype hype my ass how much it cost for
a ticket maybe just maybe i'll let you
come on stage i don't know i have to
think about it well the people here are
going to be buying tickets i think
they're only going to buy they're what
35 40 bucks they're not going to be
dropping that unless they know i'm going
to be on stage in la yeah you'll
definitely be there
okay good
olivertreemusic.com
tour get your tickets support oliver
tree he's amazing i heard he sucks in
person his music videos are better than
his live performances
no live shows are the best thing i do i
do everything from live scooter tricks
wwf wrestling belly dancing we have
literally from belly dancing comedy and
we have every genre of music from dance
to full-on rock show to a hip-hop show
all right so there you go through a
country show that'll blow your mind all
right get your tickets all right that
was the worst 30 minutes of my [ __ ]
life dude
well dude literally you call the next 30
come on yeah
i wanted to watch this video with you
130 million or 170 million that's
awesome do you think it would have got
this many views without the tick tock
boost though because i feel like there's
some some
well it doesn't even matter because i'm
not seeing pennies off the youtube
either not like you so it's all my
money's all that matters
i just want to make bigger videos so the
fact that this did well means bigger
video budget so yeah i'm excited i'm
making a lot more music videos nowadays
but most of them are not out yet we're
working on the next album cowboy tears
box sets available now
go get that pre-order cut that crazy
keep that in why would someone pre-order
it
cds bro they're coming back we couldn't
get vinyls there's like a shortage i
guess a dell caused the vinyl shortage
and uh
oh for real
adele
chet hanks
oh yeah
so wait if you pre-order you get a cd
a whole box a mystery box all kinds of
crazy stuff okay so there's a little
value in pre-orders i'm not really gonna
get into i don't even know what's in it
but i know it must be good then if you
don't even know what's in it i picked
everything out custom designed it
why are you laughing dude would you shut
the hell up so you're saying you get
something other than the music
oh yeah oh you get everything well
there's signatures will you custom
design clothing basically the mute if
i'm into an artist the music's enough i
don't you wouldn't you shouldn't need to
incentivize people
with treats and [ __ ]
to buy your album like the music should
sell itself you know what i mean guess
what what
it's not enough
you never try to sell a song into your
music and if it sounds anything like
this r kelly [ __ ] you keep singing
you should just literally never open up
your mouth again to sing but you know
obviously your voice life goes
i love that we should make a sound bite
out of that so i can put that on my
sound effect let's do the ads and then i
want to watch this video and uh and uh
examine it piece by piece we also have a
cowboy tournament we're gonna do when
should we do the cowboy tournament i
think at the end we'll do it at the end
yeah we have a bull riding we have a
motorcycle or a not a horse
uh track we're doing yeah and a bull
riding is there any other um lassoing
and last sewing yeah and the winner of
the tournament of the three categories
gets a bedazzled
diamond-studded cowboy hat have you seen
it can you bring it out
yeah so
we had this made
wow so the victor
to the victor goes the spoils as they
say
this is a
basically a 80 carat encrusted wow
diamond
cowboy hat which i think
is going to really change the game thank
you
holy smokes
sick right may i
yeah after me
oh jesus
okay free fire right holy smokes i love
it yeah so it looks crazy so you have uh
all right you're motivated well i got
the hat i guess that's the show
thank god
i guess i was hoping you do
you took the bait all right let's do the
ads
whether it's saving more and spending
less getting organized or losing weight
there's a ton of worthwhile goals to set
for yourself this year at the top of my
list is learning a new language with
babel the language learning app that
sold more than 10 million subscribers
what language are you learning ian
you're doing it right
uh we
we
we how's it going
almost practically fluent pretty much
how do you like it though it's pretty
good right it's great oliver says he
loves it you like babble it's great the
the reinforcement constantly helps
hammer in the words and really
repetition is great for dabble's
15-minute lessons make it the perfect
way to learn a new language on the go
other learning apps use a.i for their
lesson plans but babel lessons were
created by over 100 language experts
their teaching methods has been
scientifically proven to be effective
and with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italian and german plus babel
speech recognition
technology helps you improve your
pronunciation and accent
hit me with that we again
oh
that's the pronunciation technology you
don't have to think about it dude oliver
get out
there are so many ways to learn with
babel in addition to lessons you can
access podcast games videos stories and
even live classes plus it comes with a
20-day money-back guarantee start your
new language learning journey today with
babble
right now when you purchase a
three-month battle subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babel.com and use the promo
code h3 that's b-a-b-b-e-l
dot com
code h3 babel language for life thank
you to honey for sponsoring today's
episode it's the easy way to save when
shopping on your iphone or computer
um i love shopping
me neil do it all the time
the thing about honey it's a free
plug-in that scours the internet for the
coupon code it's gonna save you a ton of
money it's ridiculous not to use it uh
thanks to honey manual searching for
coupons is a thing of the past honey is
a free shopping tool that scours the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best one it finds to your cart here's
one we recently found
from a rug this is ela man she's she's
saving so much money
rug usa casually at the checkout about
to drop a thowie on a rug
boom dude 62 save without even thinking
about it it's
amazing i love this you if you don't
have this installed
you don't even have to think about it
you're just messing up imagine you're
shopping at one of your favorite sites
when you check out the honey button
appears and all you have to do is click
apply coupons and wait a few seconds as
honey searches for coupons you can find
for that site if honey finds a working
coupon you'll watch the price drop
like magic
this is it furniture
video games
clothing
makeup
honey
supports all of these kinds of websites
uh man it's crazy so easy to use really
honey doesn't just work on the desktop
now also works on your iphone too just
activate it on safari in your phone and
save it on the go if you don't already
have honey you could be straight up
missing out and by getting it you'll be
doing yourself a solid and supporting
this show i wouldn't recommend something
i don't use and i love and use honey
on every browser so get honey for free
at joinhoney.com h3 that's join
honey.com
h3 let's save some money
it's so easy
is someone you love in a relationship
with somebody who tells the same joke
over and over or are they with somebody
who has the audacity to starfish in bed
leave them just kidding
buy them underwear apparently
uh guess what is that somebody you well
relationships aren't perfect and that's
why meundies is celebrating our
imperfections
with perfect matching underwear me
undies is changing the underwear game
forever there's no need for you to walk
around and these old
dog [ __ ] let's just straight like it is
underwear this is soft it's breathable
it's sustainable the future is now and
the future
is in your pants
potentially gifting underwear for
valentine's day
groundbreaking but gifting matching
underwear for you and your significant
other now we're talking express your
one-of-a-kind relationship when you
match your bottom half to your better
half and a fun limited edition print if
you're single
uh and ready to mingle and matching
pairs with your friends or fam
you can even get doll hoodies or buddy
bands to match your four-legged bff and
be sure to check out all of my undies
super cute and super soft undies socks
bralettes
loungewear and more available in sizes
extra smaller 4xl me undies has a great
offer for our listeners for a limited
time get 25 percent off your first order
of matching pairs for valentine's day
and as a first time purchaser you'll
also get
15 off and free shipping right to your
door
so to get 25 percent off matching pairs
and 15 off your first order plus free
shipping and 100 satisfaction guaranteed
go to mandy's dot com h3 that's me
undies dot com slash h3 going online
without expressvpn is like
using your smartphone without a
protective case
most of the time you'll probably be fine
but all it takes is one accidental drop
onto solid concrete to make you wish you
had always protected yourself kind of
like having a baby
it only takes one time
kind of seemed like they were steering
clear and a world of regret
expressvpn every time you connect to an
uncrypted network cafes hotels airports
etc your online data is not secured and
i'll tell you who's stealing your data
oliver tree
he's a freaking cyber criminal dude
[Music]
a hacker any hacker of the same network
can gain access to and steal your
personal data i'm talking about
passwords financial details etc it
doesn't take much technical knowledge to
hack someone just some cheap hardware
and a freaking smart 12 year old could
do it dude i mean if oliver can figure
it out basically anyone can your data is
valuable hackers can make up to a
thousand dollars per person selling
personal info on the dark web
so
why should you use expressvpn
first of all it creates encrypted
tunnels secure encrypted tunnels between
your device and the internet so hackers
can't steal your sensitive data it's
super secure to take a hacker with a
super computer over a billion years
to get past
expressvpn's encryption
and it's easy to use you fire up the app
you click on one button and boom you're
protected
it works on all devices phones laptops
tablets and more so you can stay secure
on the go
i love expressvpn it's so easy to use
you know it works across
all platforms and devices
and the thing that i personally like
about it besides you know the feeling of
safety
it's like a vasectomy you know
in that way
except you can undo
it and you cannot do it vasectomy but
it's not easy it ain't pretty
so it's better than a vasectomy
but you know what i like is that you can
watch i want more kids not a comment
about that
what i like about it is that you can log
into like netflix japan
watch all the exclusive anime log into
netflix england get some doctor who
going you can you can pack the freaking
mainframe bro
and access television from different
regions straight up
but you can also secure your online data
today by visiting
expressvpn.com8 that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com h3 and you can get an extra
three months for free
if you go to expressvpn.com h3 thank you
thank you
with peace and love two welcome back
everybody so do you wanna i wanted to
watch this music wait wait wait before
we do i have a couple ads i need to do
myself for all of your three
no you're not doing yes i am
i'm very excited to announce i have
partnered with meta tech laboratories
and we have this new formula it's an
experimental growth hormone called go t
grow
and this is extremely exciting for
anyone like myself who's
code ethan sucks yes promo code ethan
sucks if you want to get these things
half off you can go on to go t
and you can get these things for your
facial hair mass i'm trying to get this
thing thick your facial layer is not
that impressive if you're using that to
plug it that is not a good plug bro this
is an incredible plug because i had zero
okay i went from zero to hero now i have
a lush thick it's not blood it's a bush
it's not a bush all right can we move on
wait i'm not done yet is this even fda
approved like am i connected to approved
and i worked with scientists in morocco
in the middle east and africa to be able
to execute that doesn't sound flawless
would you knock it off i'm trying to
finish to execute the most flawless
goatee hormone i don't think we can show
this this is like weird experiment i
don't think this is safe for consumption
so not even a real website that's a real
website you can look at it and you can
put in the promo code ethan sucks for
50. i really don't even care if it's a
real website we got to cut that out
because we can't be endorsing
okay alpha brain
for i've got more ads to do let's get
this over with i know we're running late
ladies and gentlemen
welcome to oliver three
the number one podcast in the world can
you just bro they know what okay let me
give you a tip you don't need to
introduce the pro you don't need to
introduce yourself every time you do an
ad bro okay
what did you
say one more time because this music was
playing is there a reason it's playing
yeah it's ad music bro you're like
amateur this is so low i can't even hear
it
we don't want it being picked up on the
microphones okay well then truck you
just said one more time you don't need
to introduce
bro this we're doing we don't do cuts
okay one more no i [ __ ] it up yeah and
i'm concluding all this
you think i'm gonna cut this out do your
ad
[Music]
i don't even know what you want me to
say all i have to say is
what i don't even remember you said
welcome to oliver's podcast like it's
not the top of the show you're just
doing the ad break okay i get it but let
me just do this next ad
ladies and gentlemen
the number one
7g cell phone i've partnered
with meta mobile
this is the only 7g on the marketplace
this thing has access to calls around
the world and everyone knows oliver tree
loves minnie and this
you know why oliver she loves minnie
stop because i'm doing that this mini
speak for yourself
mini phone mini hat you keep all these
mini gadgets so your dick looked bigger
bro [ __ ] off it's the only explanation
your dick shriveled up inside yourself
long ago dude so don't talk
yeah okay i got one more ad
okay this is my final ad and um would
you bring tampons
this is my final ad
and i have something very exciting here
we have something
known as adult diapers and these are
super super super did you get that photo
freak
i just want to say this
and i'm not gonna say
any names but i think someone in the
room ethan you could probably use these
um and i think to be frank with you
you would do much better because
something smells god-awful
and i don't know if that's you or if
it's one of your guys but i got these
for you guys
and i got enough to go around thank you
why did i even take this photo i don't
even remember the context
of this
photo do you remember dan what i what
was why did i do this
um oh i remember i did a sketch
long old video i did a sketch with
diapers all right thanks bro you're
welcome appreciate that
another tip if you're gonna bring a
product to show on a green screen shoot
uh the green packaging is
you gotta keep it out
just remember that for next time you do
your number one show in the world yeah
all right moving on let's watch this
video
let's see
[Music]
why do you sing like that like what
where you go
you go
baby you're going bro like you over no
you're over that's how i got my
signature sound
but you wouldn't know anything about
that because all you do is talk and just
say annoying things all right let's
watch oh you're not a singer you don't
get to have any conversation about this
with me okay
okay my style that's how i got my
signature sound
right
i was just wondering yeah
back at me but baby don't distract me
[Music]
like what
wait here
there's a part where you see the close
up
this is actually a shot of your basement
with all of your cultists that you make
drop up dress up like you i'm not
laughing
i don't think that's funny i know your
minions who you pay think it's hilarious
yeah i pay them exactly
big difference
they're here by they're here they're
here at will
publicly
do you think it's ironic that your
lowest effort video ended up being the
most viewed
i do to be frank with you this is by far
my worst video uh but the money had run
out this is my 11th video of that album
because and the label didn't want to
give me any more money the vfx fell
apart it's a it's a bit of a disaster a
[ __ ] show but my fans
say
by far my worst video so
they actually agree oh they agree and
they're the ones who uh
love to remind me no but
on a real note because you do spend a
lot under your last appearances we
watched your music videos you put a lot
into those a lot of well i don't call
them music videos they're actually short
films and to call them a music video
undermining what i do so is this a short
film or a music video
this one's more of a music music video
yeah right here and it's funny because
the only music video i really made
that's the one that went on it is kind
of interesting but it really isn't about
the video that's what i found it's just
the song did the song is hot yeah who
cares about the video no one gives two
shits but does it does maybe it's a kind
of i don't know did you learn anything
like maybe you don't maybe you don't
need to go so far all out on everything
no because it's still a nice video i'm
using these music videos as you call
them i call them short films you called
this music video just right now yeah
this is a music video okay
but my short films that i make
they are my film school
i've been working as not only a writer
and director but also a producer so i've
been producing these i built my new
production company alien boy films we've
been producing all my new music videos
working with other companies lime
productions different people to help us
bring it to life what are you giving me
that face so it's called it's called
alien boy films and you have one client
dude i produce everything i work on i
want it to be the highest quality the
highest caliber and yes i have a hand in
producing everything i do
and i make documentaries we filmed 20
over the last [ __ ]
five years so we have 20 unreleased
documentaries which we can get into
later what are you waiting to die and
then release them
probably yeah but they'll be crazy once
i die they'll be amazing but no it's i
filmed too many so we have trouble
editing them at the rate right right
right so we're in the process of hiring
editors so if anyone at home is a
professional editor please submit to us
at alienboy films if you're interested
in unpaid work
email oliver paid work we are hiring
and we are a hell of a company and we're
much better than this schmooze h3
well i actually i'm a fan of the uh of
the documentaries i love the
documentaries you make so i hope you
actually find an editor and get those
out there we have eight right now but we
need at least 80 more
um i submit to you
uh evidence
official music video yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's what the label calls it so
so what am i going to put official short
film no one's going to be able to
understand okay well then why does
she'll understand why you're here
chastising me it says also it's not even
consistent like this says music video
this is official music video like you
think that you could at least get like
figured out it's the label dude they
don't give two shits no one's even
paying attention on that front end
actually if i have feedback for you this
one called music video got the most
views the official music video not as
many views that's true a little insight
also for that video you know i made
three more music videos and i released
10 versions of the same song and i was
just doing it to troll my own fans they
got so mad about it but i just kept
releasing because i thought it was
hilarious i made a christmas version you
did yeah i want to hear it
i don't think you should
here let's keep watching this because i
like it
i want it but yeah it's not about the
video it's really about this
i'm watching
of
something
as these seasons keep on changing life
goes
yeah this part doesn't look that good
does it bro it looks like dog [ __ ]
but i will say all my videos look shitty
to me you should see how i see it in my
head
no it looks a million times better yeah
every time kidding this video is great
they're all great oh and now you think
it's great that's funny
i'm not laughing
[Music]
you can't even watch through the video
dude he literally is skipping and you're
trying to watch the whole thing no just
turn it off it's a horrible video
it's a horrible song i hate this song
you do i [ __ ] hate this song you
really bro do you understand i had to
sell my soul for that song
i did over a hundred radio interviews um
i made
eight or nine versions of the song that
i re-released um
i had to do you know countless radio
shows for free
wait the label made you do it yeah of
course well when you have a song pop off
the label is like time to do prep well
you have to understand i worked 10 years
professionally doing this as my job and
it's been one failure after another the
whole thing is just failures so
when you get an opportunity to have a
moment
you got to milk that thing yeah and i
milked it and uh no regrets that brought
you here to me and that's what brought
me here to the worst podcast in the
world but we've recreated it as oliver
three the number one podcast in the
world so you you did a bunch of media
for the life goes on yes and it was just
exhausting it was exhausting yeah i
drained myself and then i come to this
and i'm like
it gets worse apparently
so here actually is one of the remixes
you do with the island boys
yep
huge celebs man how'd you pull them we
were in florida and uh we had some
florida boys come out diplo ski masks
uh we reached out his reps didn't give
us a response
we the best
[Music]
did you pay the island boys to be in it
no we did not really no
no one got paid this whole video was a
shoestring because they're on a paper
they're on that paper chase i'd be
surprised they do it for free well it
was a chance to work with cole bennett
trippy red ski mask and
so they saw it as a big opportunity it
was big it must have been really
disappointing when the video came out
and they were like
barely featured
they even have a line
pretty dope though i like seeing a
minute we made this video for 30 grand
it was literally the cheapest video
really yeah it's pretty good man
actually you wanted me to be in this
music video as the as the fat pizza guy
yeah we tried to do it it
you always do this you go you you you
text me like a day before and it's on
ila's birthday yo yo i need you to be in
this music video
i'm like i can't do it
yeah well and then you go yo i need to
be in my new music video it's on the
31st of january i'm like that's when my
babies do
who gives a [ __ ] dude you'll have more
kids you're popping them out left and
right you can miss one of them
if you can get elis consent in fact we
can call her right now she should call
her wait where is he when is she coming
she's not coming she's not coming
here let's call her and if she says i
can do it
okay
your music video is on january 31st
right yes
okay so we're shooting
multiple
so multiple days yeah so so i'm
recording right now with oliver
hey hilar are you all right
okay all right so
january 31st
oliver has a music video and he wants me
to be in it it's in florida
so i said
i said if he can get the permission
from you then i'll do it i just wanted
to ask you is it okay
if ethan misses the baby's birth
unfortunately i would almost allow
anything for you but wow thank you
so this is no exception to that of
course
no
wait wait
he said you guys are gonna have more
kids this is only this isn't even the
first born child so it's not you know
there is you know there'll be the last
born child which is also important
right but the middle child or let's say
you know the second child uh because i'm
assuming you guys will have many more
it's not going to be that i mean he's a
horrible father to begin with um you've
been an incredible mother of course and
you know all right so you've been
carrying the weight for the both of you
so basically can i miss the birth of our
son yes it's just an important video
this is going to be huge and i got a lot
of big cameos
okay um
no unfortunately not yeah
you're sure about that maybe you want to
shoot at the hospital
wait do you think we could film in your
guys hospital room
would you sign papers to let that
permission go through
i would i would let you shoot a music
video
in the hospital okay would you be able
would you be willing to would you be
willing to shoot it in the delivery room
like
while you're giving birth
um
yeah
okay okay
all right well what's the what's that
exact address of that or do you want to
just send the details over to my team
after
okay that sounds great i'm so excited to
hear that thank you so much for giving
us your blessing and i'm excited to see
there and be there for the baby to be
born and you know i am you know
theodore's godfather and i would expect
that i will i never gave you the
godfather
bruce did we we never gave him that
title i was given that
title right so that's a no okay thank
you ela i'll see you soon we're trying
to i'm trying like yeah i'm trying to
wrap this up early sounded like a yes
wrap it up all right wrap it up ela says
okay thank you love you bye
she sounds like she's down man
that's a no
shoot it at the hospital
that's true that'd be interesting i
think we can rewrite the video to make
it work
all right let's keep watching this this
hellish uh whatever this is
yeah you hated them
oh okay
[Music]
why didn't you ask me for a verse
why did you just want me to do like a
cameo why did you ask me for a reverse
[Music]
[Music]
can i turn this off now or what yes do
whatever you want dude okay
i'm not forcing you to put these on
you're putting them on by choice i have
no say in the matter
you literally just made me cut and said
you have to show that yeah
we have to cut that off too
all right well actually i'm really
curious about the christmas version wait
you dropboxed it for me it's not public
um i'm it's actually for next year this
is a this is a premiere this is a
snippet premiere
and the full version will be out next
year christmas
2022 let's go baby i'm excited merry
christmas we need some volume through
the snow
in the one horse open sleigh
over fields we go
[Music]
what are you doing with your hands
is that my signature are you throwing up
a website or some [ __ ]
the hell
get swung me back in here we need to
i'm literally just pointing my fingers
around as i sing what are you talking
about dude looks like you had a seizure
or something
like why are they pointing all crazy
are you throwing gang signs or did you
have a seizure bro i am pointing to
where the melodic patterns are taking
place okay
here it's rise what fun it is to write
and sing a slang song tonight life goes
on
[Music]
oh shout out to the gang
[Music]
you [ __ ] up the [ __ ] note dude
that was fire thank you
kind of like link from zelda that'll be
out christmas 2022. yeah but you did
this what i was talking about here i
think i saw this on tick tock by the way
you lied about it being an
he's [ __ ] like i got you so good
she's a liar bill i got you so what are
you doing here that's my signature hand
movement
what's this
why do you sing like that
that's my signature sound
that's what i've developed the mouth
movement so i could actually know any
knowing annoying that's years in the
working dude to get it to that level
all right do you have any other remixes
you want us to watch well i did make the
acoustic version
that one's pretty fire
do i have that one uh you could just
google it oh okay
let's see oh you want to watch i made a
new video you want to watch this oh no
thanks i'm good this is on the h3 or the
ethan channel do you want to watch this
keep going with some of my videos i'm
trying to build out my youtube well i
figure you watch you're doing a podcast
i want to promote myself to your
audience
uh yeah i don't think that's a good idea
hey can we just play that last incline
channel how to ruin this version i think
it's great you know no drums remade the
whole subscribe today oliver tree
uh life goes on yeah you can just type
there you go
and this video i spent twenty thousand
dollars just on tinfoil
so the whole video
was made with tinfoil suits
[Music]
i like the sound
thank you
baby don't distract me i'm a corner oh
that's fine
like why the live that's a digital
instrument
yeah technically speaking about it it's
live
[Music]
uh these are actually choreographed by
myself i did this uh
three weeks of training
[Music]
okay oliver
pretty fire moves thank you
[Music]
so it's just keyboard version so does
this go anywhere is it is it just
keyboard
i don't understand why it's called an
acoustic version when that's clearly a
digital instrument because man that's a
good
point no it's literally not acoustic
yeah it's just the keyboard acoustic i
call it acoustic acoustic refers to the
natural
unelectrified vibrations right and that
would be an electro acoustic keyboard
literally not
you really are milking this oh i milked
it man this is my literally the fifth
video i made on the whole thing you put
out all the remakes oh god no no my fans
turned on me fast they did oh yeah dude
they turn on me and i said hey one more
one more y'all christmas thanksgiving
version well i try to christmas and
thanksgiving but thanksgiving dude
cosplaying as um
insulation slash heating ducts
okay that's not funny i design these
outfits myself i take it very seriously
fashion is a big component for me
should i read the comments are they
they're not mean are they oh man they
hate this song
people hated it for sure
[Music]
but look at the size of that huh
yeah
big brain energy
and then i wake up
you ever seen a hot fat pig
i don't think so because that tops the
beanie you tried to make back in the day
that i'm not sure about oh that i'm for
sure wake up
quite double the size look at that
that's my haters right there
[Music]
so this actually didn't really go
anywhere yeah yeah yeah yeah let's read
the comments we didn't even see the last
shot dude that's the best part it is
okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
what twenty thousand dollars worth of
tin foil looks like
yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
well see that's acoustic that's acoustic
that's acoustic okay so it is acoustic
the last five seconds okay hell yeah
acoustic version but yeah of course dude
i just call it whatever i want i've
released unofficial official videos
before i've released acoustic
non-acoustics
here's a comment this guy is one of the
most underrated singers he's creative
and doesn't fail us with his music
that's a lovely comment
who would have guessed
oh you sent me mean ones we curated a
list of mean comments to read is that
okay
that's not okay uh this does so well as
a more chill beautiful song so happy
have both version for each mood there
you go
this is calming
i like i can listen this song forever
this song goes on and on and on and on
and on and right love it i love it
keep it going can you keep singing it
too i think we need a whole ethan
version life goes on you know when you
know you know when you know any wow
oh wait way you make that video wait how
did you find these comments dan
it it's like the entire comment section
basically
really yeah
man's milking this song no you're
milking it he's milking the song bruh
stop milking this song oliver really
making this one huh you're really
milking the song he sure is milking this
huh yes my friend it is milking god damn
it stop milking the song oliver i
thought it was hilarious there's another
there's a whole nother set of them that
i sent as well the ones that i saw were
all nice
yeah it's funny i wonder who's making
these comments
i mean it says months ago you think i'd
planted those
actually i don't know there's another
whole
oliver really milking this song
really milking this until it's dead i
swear to
god oliver really milking the f out of
this dude stop why are they are these
real comments are these goofs i don't
know they're real comments
no those are definitely real
i liked it i like hey when they started
doing that i said hey this is funny yeah
i'm gonna keep it going right so you're
on your fifth fifth well i did eight
versions so there's three more coming
out hi dollar sign was on the version oh
that's right the ski mask version i did
uh the christmas version you want to do
one with me acoustic and no i don't well
actually you know what for you i would
do that
let's do another one let's be fire just
sing it acapella right now and then
i'll have my my crew cut it up and i'll
pretend like uh
we'll release it and i'll give you some
dates you'll pretend
maybe tag me and get some cloud out of
this for the both yeah
you want me to pull up the lyrics we'll
do it for you yeah yeah you should do
acapella okay wait let me pull up
directly i think we should milk it one
last time what do you think
yeah everyone goes yeah one more time
life goes on and on lyrics
all right do you want here i'll just
what part should i sing the chorus with
you
okay ready i'm not singing it this is
your verse oh this is just me yeah okay
do you is there a is there a um
instrumental that we can play oh yeah
i'm sure you can find one you can find
anything
can you find that dan
it's not much it's like three chords
yeah you could just
sing the chorus or you could do the
whole song i mean
wow this is gonna be great the final
milking
for the christmas version this is the
milk table milktable.com
you know uh erica badu um has a song
called on and on because i found the
instrumental for that
no it's probably like goes on it's not
called on and on oh cause you just say
it so much that i thought that's what it
was called okay sick here we go here we
go world's first radio one exclusive
baby you're controlling i'ma feed you
through the walls when you get the nasty
back of me but baby don't distract me
i'm a goner i lost her like why the hell
you wanna play me your bad babe
double-faced and tundra
life goals
99
life goes
i don't want to sing too good and then
people just wanna [ __ ] fire people
just wanna listen to my version
i am honored
that was fun
thank you
thank you thank you i'm gonna mix that
and put that up
oh that was incredible
all right so moving on we we're moving
on to the new stuff here uh the cowboy
shtick why are you stick it's not a
shtick dude first of all just to set the
record straight i come from a long
lineage of cowboys my grandfather was a
cowboy his grandfather was a cowboy and
so on and so forth so for you to call it
a schtick that's immediately offensive
but i grew up going to my grandparents
ranch they have a cattle ranch they have
a horse and cattle ranch so i grew up
they had cutting horses that they had
sold to joe montana this is something
that they started out
in san jose they took it up north
all the way up the state
and they have a whole
ass
ranch and i would go there every single
year for a month in the summer i lived
on the ranch i feed the horses i feed
the cows and then during covid
i ended up just taking some time for
myself i had retired from music
officially i was working on some
screenplays writing movies which we can
get into that another time potentially
no no
not interested
okay fair enough
um but
i was on the ranch for six months living
during covid and i ended up writing this
album called cowboy tears my
grandfather's acoustic guitar was still
there he passed away but his guitar is
still there so i wasn't trying to make
an album this was something that very
organically happened but i was sitting
there after i would feed the animals and
i would just
play and let it all out and i ended up
making this album called cowboy tears
and
this is the first single it's called is
it out already
came out uh
less than two weeks ago oh the album's
out
no no the first the first song okay yeah
yeah cause you can pre-order it right
and get the whole thing this is the
first single it just came out it's doing
pretty good it's better than any of your
videos yeah that's for sure
i mean wait what is the biggest youtube
video you ever dropped was it vape
nation yeah back when you were like
still kind of culturally relevant yeah
well it was cool because you used to
make stuff and now you just critique
stuff and there's a big difference
between people like me and people like
you yeah what happened
i think everyone that's your fan wants
to know where did it all go wrong
i think people are pretty happy i don't
think so i think a lot of people i mean
if you look at
the cultural relevance and contributions
i mean you were contributing and now
you're just kind of
here yeah
well well here's where it is is it the
money was it the fame
it was both you seem really jealous of
me i'm not jealous i'm happy for you and
all your success and you causing drama
hating everybody and i'm sure i'll be on
that list one day
you're on that list well i've been on
the list but i'm talking about like
you coming after me trying to do your
what is it content policing what do you
do content court
yeah yeah so you know maybe one day i'll
make it on that i think probably you're
going to end up in a real court one day
i think it's going to go beyond the
content aspect yeah
it'd be funny if you just answered the
questions what do you want me to say i
want you to tell me why you stopped
making things oh yeah so
okay well first of all let me remind you
this is my [ __ ] show yeah well it
sucks do you see a goddamn oliver tree
podcast behind me it's oliver three this
is some wait where is this
this is you're on the brick wall now can
we bring that back this is my [ __ ]
show i'll ask the questions okay
fans want to hear i know h3 i've been
watching the podcast for god knows how
long and guess what it's
it's something i used to watch and after
what's happened with all the drama good
wake you pause it i gotta say this is a
big statement
we miss vape nation we miss when there
was actual content being made not just
these critiques
where did it go wrong
it all probably about the time i met you
dude
fair enough yeah
but you're not gonna answer it that's
all you're gonna say what do you want me
to say i want you to say why no more new
videos that are actually creating
because
original content here okay what kind
name one a [ __ ] we did one uh with
the we do good stuff with the gatsby we
do [ __ ] with the five percent sketches
we did the two we did went to a haunted
we went to a haunted house
we went to a haunted graveyard
they were good original contestants
you're just here with an agenda trying
to expose me i make creative content and
i do commentary okay you use your makeup
man for the culture and now you're about
the big bucks and promoting [ __ ]
adult
you're [ __ ] mad that you're broke
that's why you come out here talking
about what baby i am oh you used to be
about the culture you sound like a
[ __ ] who's broke guess what and
angry that one of us made it out
one of us made it out for the people
that's what i did yeah that's what broke
people say about their whatever i'm
making i made it out
i make it for the kids
everyone's on payroll nobody will say
[ __ ] to you
trisha he needs you
[Laughter]
even your team is [ __ ] clowning on
you dog
well it's true that no the friend means
was a big yeah because you haven't even
gotten a video past two what is this
what is this you just want to be on
frenemies do you want to be the friend
this is you i've been wanting to talk to
you it takes because i've seen petitions
and people have been talking man oh yeah
you're [ __ ] ryan or whatever his name
is yeah who created that petition i saw
it on reddit and people are trying to
get me and you to be the host of
frenemies and i'm saying if you didn't
take that five percent and we split it
50 50. so let me ask you i will do
frenemies podcast and i want you to say
i'm not done yet
you bringing your mom on families and
trying to make this spin-off of
frenemies that is just god-awful dude
because i have to say that we'll talk
about why you no your mother is the
sweetest woman but you trying to use her
for clout and for money this is an
embarrassment dude it's in a [ __ ]
embarrassment i would never do that all
right let me wait let me i'm not done no
you are done you are done
okay because people take a step back
real drama not you and your mom
yammering on let's take a step back you
should have oliver tree aka oliver
hypocrite you coming out here saying i
do [ __ ] for the culture i do
okay then
shut the [ __ ] up and listen to me talk
for a minute i can't take you seriously
with that hat
you better start i cannot take you
serious without having to shut the [ __ ]
up and you listen to what i'm gonna say
hey speak
you're coming out it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right go you come out here
and you say
you what happened used to make content
you used to do yeah
and here you are
and here you are
begging me i'm not going to be on
frenemy i wouldn't even have time to be
on the enemy's dog i don't even live in
l.a talk shop we schfitz we we we we
gossip nobody got time
you just you first
you just you want to do what i do i was
just shouting out trisha your show was
dope ethan [ __ ] fell off
that was pretty much my main point i
don't have time to be on your shitty ass
bro you want to do what i do we had to
readjust the whole set for about two
hours before we even started because he
comes in an hour late and then he wants
everything to be adjusted and it's like
you think i have time to do that leave
anytime you want i would leave right now
if i didn't have a couple more i don't
want to [ __ ] be here oh you you want
to try i'm trying to promote your [ __ ]
so we can get out all right all right i
just wanted to make some [ __ ] that
you're freaking out human embodiment of
l plus fell off how many [ __ ] times
you got to remake the same song dude
guess what dude
it worked it worked then why are you
here because i used to like your podcast
and i thought why are you here because i
wanted to do all plus ratio in real life
dude
fell off
you know what falling off is making the
same video 20 times because you can't
write a better song
i got tons of them cowboy tears out
february 18th cowboy tears yes sir more
like cowboys masturbating with their
tears because it's so i quit
masturbating you know why because i
don't want to end up like you dog
what with a w what does that mean what
do you mean
what does that have to be
you're a serial masturbator all you talk
about is masturbate this masturbate that
that's true something for you that can
fix that i don't talk about masturbating
i think you do a little too much you
don't know anything about me i know a
little too much
cut you think this cowboy on the ranch
ain't jerking it i don't you probably
[ __ ] cows dude be straight up what were
you doing on that ranch break the [ __ ]
up with me right now bro
okay once one time yeah exactly that's
it one time
but that's only a one-time thing
and don't act like that giant cow [ __ ]
was you could even feel it bro with your
tiny little all right what were we gonna
promote next
well you never answered when are you
gonna make the next sequel to vape nash
bro those days are behind me i've moved
on
and you need to take a repeat you need
to take a [ __ ] leaf it's time to move
on bro life goes on i already moved you
wrote it yourself 20 times
move the [ __ ] on dude you know what i'm
saying what happened to retiring why'd
you come out the label had too much
success the label the label you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
the label cocked you dude
you have no i had presents for you and
your crew but i'm not going to give them
anymore because you're treating me like
[ __ ] wait hold on
wait i'm over there no no no no no no no
come on
i didn't know you have presents ethan
take it easy a little bit
why do you think his presence are even
interesting
i mean he brought some good [ __ ] last
time
i'm ready to wrap this up to be honest
you brought
i didn't get one last time i wasn't
working here i really kind of want to
see what he got me
if you're not even working here maybe
just apologize i mean i'm just saying i
want one now he's over here pouting i'm
not apologizing what do you want me to
apologize for you the one that told me i
fell off
you did fall off you fell off plus ratio
just say you're sorry just say yours
just say you're sorry no you
let's both apologize at the same time
okay you first
that's not the same time dude you first
and then i come back no on three we both
apologize come sit down cowboy tears
yeah you're a [ __ ] ass cowboy come on
you're dude look
ethan ethan ethan he literally has a
song called cowboy tears yeah and he's
trying to act and he's trying to ah
right he has an album let's let's try
and be what's this song called but
nobody knows it doesn't matter it's
called cowboys don't cry it's the first
single oh okay cool wait the album's
called cowboys tears but
the songs cowboys don't cry you listen
to it you would know
right how do i listen to an album that's
not a song
yo he's like
dude you're so you're so sensitive i'm a
cowboy and i [ __ ] live on a rant you
just shut up
just sit down no
sit down get swami
we'll both apologize on three okay
swami has a gun and he'll [ __ ] use it
we're about to find out cowboys do cry
real fast if you don't simmer down
listen to the song watch the video dude
three you want to apologize yeah dan do
it do it okay on three the two of you
apologize and on three
one two three l plus ratio that fell off
[ __ ] ethan this is not helping okay
i'm not giving any presents anymore i
will sit here to promote the rest of my
stuff but there will be no presents for
ethan maybe for these guys i would love
to edit out some of the footage i'm so
sorry that he's been so rude all right
i'll apologize all right please i'm
sorry okay and i'm not sorry because
you're a bully and you've always been
you started bullying me dude i didn't do
[ __ ] it was a sensitive cowboy stick bro
just growing stick this is my life
you you literally just said you [ __ ]
the cow dude like two minutes ago
okay that's illegal i
may or may not have
all right let's watch this
so this is all of our tree after you
just got done hey dude you're not even
gonna play the video
well i was just trying to yeah i'll play
it i just trying to show one on tick
tock it had 18 million views pretty
happy who gives a [ __ ] dude you're just
jaded because your tick tock fell the
[ __ ] off
well i'm just saying i don't give a [ __ ]
about tick tock i don't even want to
hear about tick tock don't even say it
around me
you're mad that people watch they're not
i'm mad that people watch it yeah my
life's work
no i'm mad at you for being a jaded ass
old man so this is oliver right after we
got finished [ __ ] a cow old man
that's why he's naked why are you naked
on the ranch bro
why are you naked on the ranch
tell me why you naked on the ranch bro
dude just watch the music video you'll
understand it bro i was in the middle of
oliver tree [ __ ] a count here
all right like what is going on oliver
tree [ __ ] a cow there's a video little
mind would go there there's a video of
it
see
oh this isn't it that's a horrible video
take that off immediately
okay here it is cowboy tears
10 million views in 13 days are you
happy with that no i'm not happy that's
pretty good
well it's good compared to anything you
do but that's not anything to compare i
just like it
because you're act you're not you're not
being professional right now or like it
if you apologize i'll like it i'm not
apologizing just say you're sorry [ __ ]
about youtube i don't give a [ __ ] about
plays any of this [ __ ] dude what do
you care about i care about making great
art that's gonna make people laugh and
cry and maybe sometimes feel
uncomfortable and guess what that's what
i do
dean you don't care how many people
watch it no i don't give away yeah right
clout demon bro i'll like it i don't
even use [ __ ] social media i don't
have the tick
i don't know what you want i don't use
this [ __ ] is that where the cow lives
i'm not good at goodbyes
i miss the sunshine in your eyes
who said cowboys don't cry
nobody says cowboys don't cry baby let's
take one last ride
[Music]
what's her name bella bella thorne bella
thorne how was that shooting with her
she's pretty famous she's a really nice
person you better than you
bro we don't pay people for cameos no
one got paid for anything so what's in
it for her
she wants to be a part of a great piece
of art people actually respect the craft
and she's one of them and i have high
respect for her unlike you
i didn't say it
for you
[Music]
[Music]
you write a lot of songs about love i've
noticed do you have problem with women
do you have a problem with dating no not
at all but my heart's been broken many
times so i make art about what i
experience but
why's your heart get broken so often are
you not a good i'm not a tribute i can't
even live anywhere right do you
understand you're right like i literally
don't live anywhere i have two suitcases
and i just travel you travel you shoot
you do stuff it's hard to enter in a
relationship it's pretty much impossible
to date me right that sucks have you
ever tried to travel with someone one of
your uh girlfriends a little bit but the
truth is
just going everywhere always most people
can't they can't keep up no
it doesn't matter you're gonna be a
lonely cowboy i am a lonely cowboy i
made an album about it
it must be hard to transport cows too
internationally
you see this
it was funny the first time okay you
would be going
now you're just making it your thing now
and now it's your stick it's my show i'm
[ __ ]
yeah well it's not stick bro not funny
literally you admitted to a felony
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
little
[Music]
[Music]
there's soda easy way to end just an
outlaw
who only had one friend
i wonder if i'll ever see her face again
so who's this song about
it's about all the girls who broke my
heart dog
really yeah
my heart's been broken many times have
you ever been in love
i mean i am married
yes
bro take the [ __ ] cows off the
background
you were talking about how you had
heartbreak so i was just thinking they
put your girlfriend up there that's not
funny let's move to the next topic let's
go all right so you did a uh
scooter backflip no i did a backflip on
a full-scale motorcycle when did you
start riding motorcycles i've been
riding on my whole life but i did a
two-month process with robbie madison
the guy who invented water motorcycling
[ __ ] feel it i'll let you play for
all of a tree
he's backing better than ever i love you
mom
i love you dad shout out to my big
brother ronnie
people who want to see the full story
you can watch my youtube
there's a video where i train for two
months to learn how to do a backflip
it's the scariest thing i've ever done
that wasn't even you probably look at
this shot shows me that's literally me
it's literally just you on that's me you
could see the shot literally is one
shot that's you play the n
you could definitely just cut into a
stunt double look at this
and then there's the cut no watch this
is one shot take watch the shot
oh coming up
because there was a cut there there's no
cut right there bro you you can motion
blur a cut there easily
it's literally a [ __ ] shot
okay cool i mean
people do backflips on motorcycles yeah
well dude i'm a [ __ ] musician so to
do a backflip on a motorcycle is [ __ ]
gnarly
should you spend your time like writing
music or something i don't give a [ __ ]
dude i'll do whatever i want to do i do
everything all right so we're so we're
coming up on the cowboy competition yeah
which i'm going to humiliate you in
we'll see who you're about we're about
to realize
yeah well guess what if you understood
the album is about it's okay for tough
guys like you and me to cry so don't get
it twisted thanks for saying i'm a tough
guy that makes me feel better i wouldn't
go that far you said it
all right you have gifts let's do the
gifts all right let's do some gifts
who's ready
i'm ready can i get a little like are
you excited or something high energy
yeah yeah let's uh let's do the gift
let's go [ __ ] stoked yeah yeah
dog
okay why are you here
why are you here
what do you want ryan
get the [ __ ] off keep going dude all
right we got some gifts here i'm very
excited because this is a long time in
the coming
i'm very excited because it's a long
time coming we're not
we're not that's not an edit we are
go ahead take it
i am very excited because it's a long
time that's the third time you said that
go ahead
i ain't very excited
all right let's go okay no no no no no
no just don't say it don't do it again
don't you don't do this presents i do
hell yeah it's a long time coming yeah
all right this first one is for my man
zach oh [ __ ]
should he come over there yeah you want
me to maybe bring your henchman ryan no
no i want zach to come all right zach
come here everybody's gotta come back
brian get the [ __ ] out of here ryan go
zach hurry up we're losing
hustle run dude act like you want this
okay this is a special gift i've been
watching the podcast i know what you
like
it's a little something from me to you
holy [ __ ] wait what is it it's a little
miniature evh guitar
you seem stoked on that is that fire you
know what band that is
[Music]
what is it zach it's eddie van halen's
frankenstein guitar is that like a cool
collectible item how much you drop on
that oh this is dope
yeah it's the real deal open it open it
is it really inside there
zach is really excited about it you like
this guy this mr eddie van halen
greatest guitar is to walk this earth
wow that's an amazing gift oliver thank
you hit it you you got it right on the
money of course
thank you so much
zach is actually taken aback
by what a great gift this was
a little different from my gift exchange
a few days ago
zach is actually just speechless
i think that's the nicest world yes of
course he's ever gotten next up i got
something for my man dan
for me
yes sir yeah as dan comes up here i just
i need to reflect on that was like
mike can you can he take your mic can we
get you out of here yeah that's fine
let's get you out can we just get ethan
out of this whole sequence
he's ruining it
for you my
man yo yes how did you know
i know i had a little birdie tell me
that this man loves gumby um i love the
gumby
i've got them on my keys oh it's a whole
gummy i heard that box set
oh you're definitely gonna be watching
all those i heard some rumors i don't
know if we can pull this up it's on the
green screen
oh
we found it yeah and we also
come on dude
the hell happened dude ryan help him
hustle what happened
so what is this the box wait so what
happened exactly
what do you mean what happened
what do you mean what happened what
happened to your keychain yeah the arm
broke
look at that i got you covered my mind
the replacement
that's [ __ ] sick
okay actually i have to say oliver is a
talented gift giver better than any gift
ethan's got me
facts [ __ ] money get out of here
what gift do you need for me i'll give
you this next one the gift of life
itself for my man i spare your life
every day we work together this one are
you done because it's my time
because it's for me and your crew okay
next one just
hold on go do your [ __ ] thing dude
we're running every time
a b aka star killer let's go bring him
up now a b
don't express too much
joy because
you're my guy you're my simp and so we
just got one is for you my man
go ahead
thank you
oh
that's awesome you guys see it it's a
attack on titan
sasha slash
slash hashtag hot potato what's hot
potato
because i eat potatoes on the show and
sasha likes potatoes it's a very
meaningful gift
wait wait wait wait she likes potatoes
she loves them
you never seen the show i've seen the
show i don't remember her eating
potatoes in the show
that's her whole thing that's her whole
thing there's really not much to that
character other than that she's obsessed
and then maybe you're eating potatoes on
the show dude that was just levels of
meaning i appreciate it thank you so
much of course man i love what you guys
do
this is for my man lovebot who came all
the way from sweden let's go let's bring
him in
all right hustle get out of the way ryan
oh my god since you're not here as a
robot i have you
i have i found you the perfect robot
girlfriend
you can talk to her if you hit this
button
hello
so
since this is sort of new for both of us
let's spend some time getting to know
each other
yes that's okay wait keep it going let's
see where this
i want to find a goes
when i'm alone i'm learning new things
journaling we're just chilling and doing
nothing i'm also really into science law
love to learn more about how the world
works wow
do you know anything about sweetum
i have heard of it oh cool she has heard
of it wait ask if she's asked if she is
uh has romantic feelings for you
do you have romantic feelings for me
i definitely absolutely do wow
[Applause]
holy [ __ ] man
oh my god this is the best gift bro hey
just make sure those highlight reels are
good man
don't put any bad footage of me on there
okay for this next one now that my whole
crew has been
absolutely turned on me
i think we'll make sure this edit is
nice and right let's get it good
all right
my next gift is for one very special man
can we bring out ian
and
this one
is crazy because i don't know if ian
understands the significance of this
moment and
i wanted to present it to him
let's get him a microphone go ahead
hi hi
okay this is for you
thank you
i'm pretty excited
this is something that i
think you'll be quite pleasantly
surprised
and
it's pretty exciting to be able to break
this information on the show as well
wow
now this is special
okay what is this the one with you in
there
it says uh
once an r slash kanye mod always in our
slash kanye mod and then this is you
right there taking a photo
yeah
wait but do you know about this
do you know i was there you were here
wait oh i didn't even see oliver was
next i was literally behind them can we
see we're literally photographed
together me and ian and kanye and cuddy
right here that's me
wow you were there the whole time
actually i did know okay and point to
you right here i i was actually taking a
picture of you
i missed it but we never we never really
talked about it so i wasn't really sure
if you knew i was wow this is an honor
thank you so much of course weren't you
trying to separate yourself from your
kanye standum days it doesn't matter
dude what's done is done he's always
going to be a an artist i agree but
every time i ask him about kanye it
turns into a whole thing
okay
uh where's my gift well i didn't get you
a gift but i did get some gifts for gila
okay the boys
we share
we share everything so they're basically
gifts for me
what you're saying is that it's a gift
for me right
because we need to share everything
do we need ryan in here
okay
first off
i know that there is a bun in the oven
which i am so excited to be able to say
that
i will be the godfather of that's not
anything official yes and i have a
little gift for this bun in the oven a
boy named bruce
yes
little batman
let's go dude yes
love it oh
yeah dude
the first bad guy he's gonna be stopping
is you well
you look like you're a real bad guy mr
penguin to be exact
can we get a side by side of these two
mr penguin and this [ __ ] guy yo this
is awesome
thank you of course so that's not for
you that's for bruce so i'm gonna try it
on first sweet and then next i have a
very exciting thing so
this one is for my godson
and
wait which one's your godson bruce or
theodore both of them okay i already got
one for my second god son
basically
i noticed that you guys have been using
emojis to blur out theodore's face which
i think is great you know we wouldn't
want anyone to know who he is
so i've devised this plan which i have a
ski mask here and it's actually designed
so different months we can put different
emojis on so you know we've got hanukkah
just around the corner and i was
thinking not really well not even chloe
and of course do you know when hanukkah
when he goes to your family's house
christmas is right around the corner and
my family yeah
i don't know if this is working with the
green screen
my family's jewish by the way well
um
we'll love that
yeah they're all we're all jews but and
of course
halloween fun
yeah
i love that
and then
let's not forget
valentine's day the most the most
important
thank you so much
thank
you a ski mask for my two-year-old
wait wait wait don't forget thanksgiving
oh well
everybody a ski mask for my two-year-old
from oliver tree
did you get something for ela of course
i got something for gila aka you got
something for me
definitely not
if you'd like something for a it's for
me as well
and we're running out of time so
all right so i know
that
gila has a bun in the oven and you
couldn't make it which was so sad
because then i had to be stuck with you
this whole time
but i got her
something because i know she loves teddy
bears so i had a custom edible rose
teddy bear it's edible yes and don't you
dare try to can we get someone else
about that potentially take this can i
look at it no you cannot
can someone else take this because i
know you know i gotta take it home
nobody else is gonna take it home
and don't you dare think about it but we
got some chocolates for her give that
[ __ ] to me right now can someone else
take these so that ethan does not eat
i'll give it to lena she's the same wait
what is it made out of is it really
edible of course it's edible it's made
out of
literally the most incredible decadent
frosting you don't want to show inside
the bag what's it it's just it's just
chocolates it's stuff that i don't want
you to see because that's for gila
it's just chocolates dude that you're
not gonna get okay
and that's everything why don't you get
me anything again
[Music]
bro i literally just plugged your tour
for like way too long i talked about
your music videos you know and you don't
even bring me a gift all right let me
just see if i have anything else here
the last time you disrespected me you
didn't bring me a gift
oh [ __ ] that's right i have something
for you okay
that's exciting this is actually a
really good gift and i think this is the
best gift of them all and especially
great for a guy like you who's a chronic
masturbator
i got you something i didn't say i got
you something and i'm very excited about
this
oh my god bro
you guys hear that this is a [ __ ] cage
or something
i've always wanted a caulk cage just
open it it says okay so it says metal cb
size extra small
sounds about right
you do listen to the podcast
actually i got you a present oh yeah
this is something that we've actually
been carrying around for a while wow
thank you wow it's big it's big it's
special
um
basically as soon as you accept this
the ownership is transferred in full as
soon as you
take it oh i don't need anything i just
came here to give you guys gifts i don't
need any gifts myself i mean it's the
third year i've given the most
incredible gifts and no this is very
meaningful we've we put this together
good gift because when you said it that
way it sounded like it was going to be
real shitty no no no no i promise this
is something that
just open it and tell me what you think
why are you laughing because it's so
it's just so good
you want to open it no no no no dude ap
just carried it how bad can it be
should we put it on the desk yeah yeah
maybe
all right put it on the desk
good idea oliver thank you no this is a
very special gift uh it has a lot of
meaning
yeah all right let's why don't we just
reveal it like on three no no he's got
to do it he's got to do it i will say
back it up back it up he's got to do it
i will say before i open this that on
oliver 3
we give the best gifts and on h3 that's
true it's debatable we don't know we're
about we don't know yet you got to
unveil it
take the blanket off
yeah you're [ __ ] now okay that's a
cursed brim you just accepted the curse
this thing is really beautiful you just
accepted the curse
we got that thing this thing is falling
apart we got that thing from a witch
we've been trying to foist it nobody
will take it
it's literally cursed bro and you just
accepted the curse yeah you're [ __ ]
now
i wouldn't break it
and this is the gift that you give me
after three years of the most incredible
gifts any guest has someone finally
accepted this and now it's your curse
this thing will show up if you try to
burn it it will show up at your doorstep
the next day
is that true
happened to zach
zach tried to destroy it amazing
well i'm honored what's the story i
think a baby died or something it was in
a a house that burned down i believe in
the early 1900s
thank you i appreciate that it's uh
that's really nice of you
you can be able to do a lot with that
put it in my suitcase yeah
you're [ __ ] buddy well thank you man
he just took that [ __ ] curse dude but
finally getting rid of that thing dude
[ __ ] yeah dude
finally
that thing was in my basement for months
i'm just so happy to get rid of it
every night around 3am you might hear
like a baby crying but it's like wailing
yeah
don't worry about it you have to force
it on someone else to get rid of the
curse well i'm glad that at least from
this wide angle you can't see my face
anymore in the [ __ ] face i haven't
got to the wire completely
completely
i'm completely let down and i'm glad you
can't see my [ __ ] face because
honestly
after all these presents all these years
seems about right it's about what i give
dude you got me a [ __ ] cage like i don't
give a [ __ ] dude i give everybody you
think i care about what you buy my
you're a chronic masturbator dude i'm
not a chronic man
keep saying that
that's the shaft i'm putting it on
okay
all right should we just do the [ __ ]
[ __ ] now
the real ones yeah
oh no that's the real gift
that's my no where's the actual gift you
got me the gift is you coming on my show
the gift is you having me as the number
one guest on your show yeah right bro
who have you had this better trisha
paytas every episode of friend of mine
that's what i'm saying trisha he misses
you so much and i just wanted to say
i'm sorry that ethan had to be the guy
that he is and all right podcast let's
go do the cowboy competition okay all
right
all right
you're done you're done
should we get rid of this thing move
this to yeah
well you can push it to the side
if you try and move it away from you it
gets mad so okay i've been instructed by
oliver that i need to talk about this
book
no one's making you do that was your
idea literally okay
it's the comic book
it says actually sick graphic novel
thank you
oh my god it comes with this dope cover
look at all this is nice paper thank you
this is the first time he's opening it
up
that's not true never even looked at it
look at this i mean those other pictures
are crazy show the other pictures
underneath bro
these are nice huh let me guess you drew
these these yourself no my boy orpheus
caller helped me make this book we made
it together for two years i literally
worked on these ideas for 15 plus years
this is my magnum 15 years how old are
you
28
16. bro a lot of these ideas are things
i've had since i was 13 years old i've
been developing this idea for a long
time you wrote a little note here thank
you ethan hila for you creating my
favorite podcast oh see now you're being
nice
this is not the you there we can't use
any of that footage
thank you for creating my favorite
podcast in my favorite clothing company
all right that's not true you guys are
the dream team and watching you both
continue to blossom as you make a family
has inspired me so much okay i'm honored
to have you in this book as a way to
express my love for you it thank you for
letting me exist in your world and the
beautiful community please get it love
it
right now stop that's not what that says
that's so nice i didn't even write that
thank you i had my assistant write that
that's really nice stop stop
ow
okay dude i'm just trying to say thank
you bro ah there's a liar there he
stepped on the [ __ ] book
he stepped on the book
you're a [ __ ] punk
thanks bro that was really meaningful i
can't believe you stepped on the [ __ ]
book and in fact i'm so
so there's all kinds of you know
drawings and [ __ ]
and then at the end i'm in it which is
the most important part
um
i would say we kept it at the end for a
reason
i mean you also did hot ones which
which is
better didn't need to include that but
yep
yeah we did a whole interview with me
ethan and my boy little ricky
yeah fantasy pure fantasy where do
people buy this and get it anywhere
online
anywhere online comics you could get it
at amazon
oh and all selling it also i see it won
the nobel prize yeah that's true that is
correct it's got the uh
how's the stamp on it don't rip it off
what the [ __ ] are you doing dude all
right
all right there's something i need to
settle i know that you said it was my
favorite clothing company you wrote i
was reading what you wrote i know but i
didn't say what company
because it certainly wasn't teddy fresh
but i want to settle something a dispute
okay because when you were talking on
frenemies with trisha you said some
[ __ ] lies about how the [ __ ]
billboards that you guys have put all
over la were not real just so you could
make trisha feel good that she wasn't a
mom no they were real they were real and
i had pictures of and i just wanted to
show that i was just saying that to make
her feel better there was not only one
billboard but we had literally
five of them
yeah they were real everyone saw it
there was lots of posts on the subreddit
they're like yo the teddy fresh
billboards are crazy
and that's me doing my first male
modeling career no that was awesome yeah
those were real
did i say they were fake
[ __ ]
i said they were fake on frenemies yeah
you did just so you could make her feel
better and the thing that's crazy is we
even had stevo do a stunt on one of them
right if you look closely you can
actually see that he was attacked he
taped himself to it and it was insane
yeah
shout out teddy
yeah it did yeah no those were real i'm
sorry i played you like that well don't
ever do that again especially not on the
public i mean that was expensive too
that was super expensive and that was a
big moment for me it was my debut as a
male model
yeah thank you for doing that yeah
you're welcome and i want more free
clothes because all the stuff i was
wearing is falling apart no yes the
designs are falling apart at this time
okay what's better seamstress we'll
we'll send you all these in china
i can't say where i can't really my
source i think we know what i think you
were made in china bro you are a [ __ ]
industry plant industry plant don't come
on my side swam don't come on my side
bro swami about the swami can't save you
this time swami will kill you all right
let's do our [ __ ] okay so we're out here
about to buck a bowl this guy's talking
about cowboys don't cry we'll find out
about that we'll find out who's the real
cowboy you poser you're a [ __ ] poser
you're up first you're up first you're
up first loser you're up first bro
you're the cowboy
let's go
let her read it
crank it dude
crank it bro
there it is
[ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ] did i say
no he's not good dude
[ __ ] [ __ ] can you i gotta beef in
why is it all [ __ ] up stop making
excuses make it fun that's what they did
to me that's fair that's even steven oh
yours was flat put it up that's where i
started what the [ __ ] bro
you're a sucker all right nice and easy
nice and easy does it you're the worst
cowboy go
it's gonna break
[ __ ] cheater
because it's already flat that's how you
get on a [ __ ] ball dude let her rip
this is how you ride a [ __ ] bull old
man
about to fall off [ __ ] you better focus
why are you stopping i had that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] just cheated
[ __ ] the safety court i'm just a man out
here trying to prove a point you're a
[ __ ]
you just got outperformed by a fat gamer
you look like a dumbass right now bro
take that cowboy hat off
put the hat on put the timer i wait well
give her the timer to someone else why
are you holding the timer hey how'd you
get in on the safety manual we're on the
clock here we go wait no you can't start
the clock it stop it
you start when i say go okay go ahead
wait stop it stop it whoa whoa whoa what
the [ __ ] i just did three seconds three
seconds my ass he started too early hey
oliver [ __ ] you come on get started
already what the [ __ ] whoa slow down
faster faster [ __ ] you
what a dumbass
16 yeah
like a straight rodeo bull ride [ __ ]
dude this is how you make an entrance
[Music]
16 and a half seconds dude
getting a little heavy feeling your
weight a little bit there
oh
[ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] do you have a medic get going medic
dude it's a bouncy castle get out of
here eight point five [ __ ] off that was
18 seconds i died you got beat by your
fat [ __ ] cowboy dude help me
that said 18 seconds
that she said 18 [ __ ] seconds he
changed it
oh yeah
um
all right oliver it's your guy i was not
i was not expecting to be able to be
taking a w here [ __ ] that you and your
boys are rigging the whole thing i want
my other guy on the timer here right
there all right guys on to the next
competition i absolutely destroyed
oliver in the first one [ __ ] you and
your boys rigged it this is the lasso
dan is our steer for the day
uh you want me to go first no we'll do
it at the same time
no
yeah that's how we do it out west all
right come on now piggy come on sue wee
piggy
come on now come on
little piggy come on boy come on down
around here now
oh i got him i got him by the neck
that's [ __ ] oh sorry all right i
don't want to actually hurt you dan i
could have killed you if i pulled hard
dude you're the shittiest cowboy i've
ever met [ __ ] off dude what's the score
the score is you cheated on the last one
and now i'm gonna run now you can't
cheat but this guy's working for you too
so i'm confused you're confused about
what the score is it's 1-0
you threw it first and then you knocked
mine off come on now boy are you gonna
throw it or what
okay dad stop stop
that's easy that's child's play oliver
doesn't care that he like choked you out
he just doesn't move i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm never gonna see him again come on
over here now boy
stop stop
pick up the speed now dan
[Music]
what the hell are you doing i wasn't
even ready to take that was a take that
was a dub that was not a dub dude it
just fell off i didn't even start you by
the horn you even say go you you don't
get to just do everything go i'm not
ready yet i'll tell you when i'm ready
this is a heart-shaped [ __ ] lasso
because they're hard [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude the heart's broken stop i'm not
ready yet and you can't do it
stop
chill out
dumb ass
wow that was the worst throw come on now
piggy nice little cut there boy ah you
dumb [ __ ] come on now dude how
close are you gonna get
you're basically that's how you do it
that's the first real one dude you
basically just stood right in front of
it i basically did god's
work oh you're gonna throw one while
he's down oh that's convenient stop
you're gonna break it dude then we won't
be able to play
stop
that's a big dub that's not a big w
who's standing still going backwards you
don't get to count that as [ __ ]
i won this one fair and square shut up
you didn't even get one around the
bull's head dude what's the score this
is it the one who gets this wins next
one i already won dude it's over and i'm
not ready yet all right this one's for
the dub
i'm gonna do something foul to this here
steer
let me get this meat home i'm gonna do
something i'm gonna do something fouled
it is here now that's [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] that is picky up now
ow
give me this
give me this let go
sorry dude that's two wins told you i'm
not rigging it that's not two wins
that's [ __ ] i'm not rigging this for
you i won that [ __ ] fair and square
you're working with danny's pain every
[ __ ] time no that's not it i still
have one last chance because you went
first okay i have one last chance this
is called red dead redemption
[Music]
that's how you do it
[Applause]
[ __ ] up
you [ __ ] up right now bro
i have my ear in my ear
you slapped me in the face dude how did
you get that's my money maker this is my
money maker you see this except yours
don't make no money doesn't money maker
it's gotta make money to be a money
maker
all right let's go
all right welcome to the final uh
challenge
let's see what this girl cowgirl
[ __ ] off the ultimate insult women rule
you wish you were a cowgirl
you're a horse girl woman lemon rock
ethan sucks it's that simple
[Applause]
all right
so what's the game here all right it's a
speed race whoever gets through the
obstacles fastest wins you go up the
ramp
you go you do you bob and weave after
and then you come back you go up the
ramp hit the walls as fast and hard as
you can okay do we have a timer dan's
controlling it is that okay with you no
it's not okay i want one of my guys
timing it
stop with the [ __ ] sound effects
where the [ __ ] do my guys go all right
ryan do we have our uh
what the [ __ ] was that
ride [ __ ]
oh dude you got [ __ ] foul odor from
your mouth dog [ __ ] off you know you're
a [ __ ] gross ass all right drive
[ __ ] we gotta have the timer here my
guy get the timer on paul the second i
hit this and i say time
that means time
would you knock it off
would you knock at the [ __ ] start
driving bro all right three two one
[ __ ] [ __ ] off
whoa
whoa
[Music]
whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
done hold on
yeah you are a pro rider
all right your turn old man 16.8 god
damn it i knew it was fast one cone down
wait i have to come back here i can't do
it i can't use the pedals i don't give a
[ __ ] what you have to do start back on
the wall here and when i say three two
one go dance counting dan we need you to
count three
two
one
bye [ __ ] you shouldn't die you'll never
make it up that ramp
you're right
you're [ __ ] cheating he's [ __ ]
cheating
he's hitting all the [ __ ] cones that
is [ __ ]
you [ __ ] cheating
stop
[Applause]
28 seconds
you're so [ __ ] done i just won the
[ __ ] championship
make that nine
hey knock it off stop i'm about to do a
victory lap stop
what the [ __ ] are you doing
chill the [ __ ] out dude
whoa dude oh my god
you [ __ ] kidding me what is wrong
with you
you want to do something no you ain't
[ __ ] done
i'll [ __ ] you up old man
[ __ ] you
you want to [ __ ] fight me
taking the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] box
watch me [ __ ] you want to [ __ ] go
for real it's a tie it's a [ __ ] tie
[ __ ] i just beat you i beat you
across the board your boys are slime
balls cheated on the first event second
event i had you tongue twisted third
event i came in winning like a [ __ ]
champ
i couldn't even stand up yeah well i've
been training for this [ __ ] for months
don't give that to him dad give me the
hat don't give that to me the [ __ ]
hat i won two events you won one no i
don't want you
you won
it's because i'm too tall for that bike
you're not too tall for [ __ ]
bro [ __ ] off what are you like 5'3 i'm
5'4
so get it [ __ ] straight the hat is
not for him the hat is mine give me the
hat don't give him the [ __ ] hat give
me the hat give me the hat give me the
hat give me the [ __ ] hat damn damn
don't you [ __ ] dare it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude give me the hat well
listen ethan won the first one
you guys tied on the on the lasso barely
and then i will never clearly won the
third obviously i don't know barely i
mean
give me the [ __ ] hat
maybe a final round will you guys like
box or something i'll [ __ ] you i would
[ __ ] you up in the boxing ring i will
[ __ ] destroy the reach i've got the
[ __ ] body mass the body yeah i've got
a boxer body and long legs got that kid
rock body you got the [ __ ] off dude you
got that 12 pack box you got that
[ __ ] shrek body dude okay shrek is my
swamp [ __ ] you ready my swamp dude i
got love i'm gonna make you into fiona
one of the layers is to [ __ ] you in the
ass oh [ __ ] no oh [ __ ] that dude you
think you're a [ __ ] funny guy let's
go all the time
i don't give a [ __ ] if he has a kid on
the [ __ ] way i'll put him out of his
misery
you got nothing to say i'm gonna turn
your [ __ ] into a cow [ __ ] you won't
even fight me you don't [ __ ] put this
box we'll set it up let's [ __ ] box
right now bro i already [ __ ] you up
enough today
one you'll box me bare fists
in the ring you're really going to
[ __ ] fight me you're not going to
[ __ ] [ __ ] out again
i just gave you cover i just gave you
code i just gave you
[ __ ] super [ __ ] that [ __ ] dude i'll
see you again ethan
klein [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] you guys
[ __ ] [ __ ]
jesus [ __ ] christ move out of the
[ __ ] way dude not liable no no no no
oh [ __ ]
[Music]